I don't understand how you got in here
before I was in here that's crazy
never understood that
what up
Santiago Speedy evoking yourself Ben Ben
what up Beats
what's up guys
how's it going
when you put milk 74 back on we just had
them on like a month ago
hi I'm gonna not smoke a bowl off camera
oh sorry
you guys ready
oh so quick explanation if you just
watched my Instagram okay
so I try to I'm trying to I used to take
care of my face I used to work out heavy
I used to care about how I dressed and
then I just started making a lot of
money when I was a kid that's really
what happened I started selling hella
packs and I was like bro I don't have
time for that don't care I'm trying to
sell this weed and then I just forever
to stop I just got fat fatter I used to
be like skinny relatively and then
that's what happened man
and then now now it's now it's now we're
here
so
um I started trying to take care of my
face again you know I mean the Skin Care
guys this is what happened
there's two bottles this lady gave me
one's an exfoliator
one's a high uh hydration cream I mixed
them up I have been putting exfoliator
on my face and leaving it on the most
dehydrated host yes Marty the most
dehydrated host ever guys I have been
leaving it on for four days I have been
doing an acid peel basically for four
days on my face and I was wondering why
I was breaking out I rarely break out
and I was like why am I getting all red
bro
I realized last night do I still grind
my teeth dang you watch for a while I do
not grind my teeth anymore the
Invisalign so I had like straight teeth
but I got Invisalign two three years ago
because it fixes your bite and that's
why I grind I grind my teeth so bad in
my sleep I would wake up with dust like
this
I go like that you see like little
grains little grinds up my teeth
my whole life
and then uh the Invisalign they I
thought they're just trying to sell me
on Invisalign nah it fix these lights
and I do not grind my teeth anymore
isn't that crazy I don't grab my teeth
at all
I fell asleep with no mouth guard on New
Year's Eve didn't grind my teeth at all
super cool but yeah I'm trying to like
take care of my skin and face again
because I I see myself guys I see myself
on these videos and I'm like bro you
look old
there's there's a couple times in 2022
where I look at the video and go
is there a filter no that's me that's me
wow
um so I I'm taking care of my face
because I don't want to start looking
old and then let it go try to
try to preserve you know what I'm saying
so yeah that's what I'm doing right now
and then I ended up giving myself an
acid deal
yes happy birthday to Goblin oh so
that's what happened
after the young mic after this episode
after we filmed it I went to the
bathroom when he left I looked in the
mirror I went
oh I am shiny I was glistening and then
I realized last night that it's because
I didn't I
that's me
that was a genuine reaction I found out
mid going to sleep last night
where's the lighter okay
oh so last night guys I tried the very
first indoor legal push trees weed
legally
our grows are up
I'm not trying to talk about it too much
but push trees weeds come in 2023
massive facilities massive
or Morgan free until yeah Tony brought
it over last night ooh this one can you
tell we didn't like it
we put it out well that's not going in
our jars that is not going under our
name so I'll cut that strain kick it out
of the room
um I'm excited I've been working on this
bike over a year thought we had one and
we just dropped a strain this one's like
a full-on pens hash Edibles everything
it's gonna be very cool
um
yeah
so oh I can't sell it on here damn it
I'm not gonna smoke on here let me take
a quick breath
let me take a breather you know doing
the podcast you have to take some
breaths YouTube Nobody's smoking this
that was a vase
that was a base
oh my God
just a breath
foreign
guys starting today
I'm going to
not stop smoking weed I'm gonna
wean myself off the weed a little bit
not forever just till Friday this uh
Friday is our Ted Talk Marty and I if
you do we've been talking about a lot
Marty and I are going to be speakers at
the first Ted Talk of the year and uh I
do not want to be going up there oh you
know what I mean because I smoke a lot
lead so when I mean cut down like I'll
smoke like five bubbles
you know what I'm saying
I just want to be prepped ready to go
the second I step off the second I step
off that stage I'm ripping out I'm Gonna
Roll the fattest joint
um yeah I'm excited Marty and I are
about to study tonight
here it is
excited
boom all right there we go guys two
minutes left I'm gonna hop off thank you
so much for being on the live let's go
straight over to this new episode this
new episode is I think over two hours
long and I know uh you guys have been
waiting for it Marty is still editing
because it's the longest Story Time Ever
Marty we are already at an hour long and
Marty still has an hour of footage guys
this might be an hour and a half long
story time to End season four I don't
think I've ever ever ever ever ever
talked this long on story time and it is
very
very
complex all right here we go guys this
next story time hopefully coming out
today if not it's coming out tomorrow
but that being said new new episode
dropping right now editing this Beast as
we speak exactly Marty's going hard guys
thank you so much I'll see you in the
video drop a like young Mike video
coming right now
sorry have a dope essay